give us your level of optimism at this
point are we going to be okay the
there's a lot of climate exaggeration
you know that climate is not the end of
the planet so the planet's going to be
fine uh we're not going to completely
reverse development so you know when we
went from 10 million kids dying per year
in the year 2000 down to 5 million we're
not going to reverse that it's going to
slow down our progress and so things
like climate adaptation which doesn't
get hardly any uh visibility that's
become very important for the poor
countries and yes it is a burden on them
a significant burden on them that you
know it's not they didn't create the
problem we created the problem so this
is all numbers uh you know will we hit
1.5 degrees no will we hit three degrees
no we'll be below we'll be in that range
the lower the better